There are two whole videos of Canadian Academy on
the standard record and why we are interested.
There are also some examples.
In this video I want to use the algebra collection 1
from ck12.org and make some examples of a standard entry.
Let's take some things written
with standard recording.
Just as a reminder, the standard record is useful because
allows us to write either very large or too many
a small number, in ways that are close to our brains,
first - recording, and second - understanding.
Let's write some numbers.
For example, 3,102 by 10? 2.
I want to write it as a numerical value.
It's already done with a standard record.
It is written as a work of a number and 10 of a second degree.
How do I write this?
just like an ordinary number?
There is a slow and fast way.
The slow way is to say, this is the same thing as
3,102 by 100, which means if you multiply 3,102 by
100, will be 3,1,0,2 with two zeros in the back.
Then we have 1,2,3 numbers after the decimal point,
and this will be the right answer.
This is equal to 310.2.
The faster way to do is simply say: Look,
now I only have 3 before the decimal point.
Taking something from 10 to the second degree,
I will move the decimal point to 2 to the right.
3,102 at 10 ^ 2 is the same thing ...
if I replace the decimal character with 2 because
this is 10 at second degree ... this
is the same thing as 310.2.
This is perhaps a quick way to do this.
Each time you multiply by 10, you shift the decimal point
to the right with 1.
Let's make another example.
Let's say I have 7.4 at 10 ^ 4.
Let's do it quickly.
Let's shift the decimal point with 4 to the right.
7.4 at 10 ^ 4.
At 10 ^ 1, you will get 74.
Then at 10 ^ 2, you will get 740.
We will have to add 0 here because we have to
we shift the decimal point.
10 per third, you will have 7,400.
Then 10-4, you will have 74,000.
Notice, I took the decimal point
I moved 1, 2, 3, 4 characters.
That's about 74,000.
If I had 74 and I had to move the decimal point by 1
to the right, I had to put 0 here.
I multiply it by 10.
Another way to think about it is that I need 10 intervals
between the leading figure and the decimal point.
Right here I only have 1 position.
I need 4 intervals. 1, 2, 3, 4.
Let's take a few more examples because I think the more
examples, the better you will understand what is happening.
I have 1.75 at 10 in grade -3.
This is the standard record I just want to write
the numerical value of this.
When you multiply something by 10 in the negative,
you shift the decimal point to the left.
That's 1.75.
If you multiply it by 10 degrees -1.
you will go 1 with the left.
But if you multiply it by 10 at -2, you go
left with 2.
And you will have to put here 0.
If you multiply it by 10 to -3, you will go 3
left and you'll need to add another 0.
Move the decimal character 1, 2, 3 to the left.
Our answer will be 0.00175, which is the same thing as 1.75
10 at grade -3.
We can check if we have the right answer,
if ... the unit is here if we count 1, 1 inclusive,
and the zeros to the right of the decimal character that should be equal to
the negative degree here.
You have 1, 2, 3 numbers after the decimal point.
This is the same thing as the -3 degree.
You get thousands, this is 1 thousand.
Let's do another example.
Actually, let's mix them.
Let's start with something that is written as a number,
and then write it down with a standard record.
Let's say I have 120,000.
It's just a numeric value and I want to write it
with standard recording.
I can write this as ... I take the lead figure - 1.2
times on ... just count how many characters
after the leading figure.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
1.2 times 10-5.
To understand logic,
10-5 is 10,000.
1,2 ... 10-5 is 100,000.
This is 1.2 times ... 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
You got 5 zeros.
That's 10 ^ 5.
1.2 per 100,000 will be 120,000.
It will be 1 and 1/5 per 100,000, or 120,000.
I hope you do not despair.
Let's do another.
Let's say the numerical value is 1 765 244.
I want to write this with a standard record, I take it
the leading figure, 1, I place the decimal point.
And everything else after the decimal point -
7, 6, 5, 2, 4, 4.
And then you count how many numbers there are between
the leading figure ... I guess you can imagine
the first decimal place.
Because there could be numbers that continue here.
Between the leading figure and the decimal point.
You have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 characters.
This at 10 ^ 6.
10 ^ 6 is just 1 million.
That's 1,765,224 per million, which is logical.
Approximately 1.7 million per million is approximately 1.7 million.
That's a little more than 1.7
million is therefore logical.
Let's do another.
How to write 12 with a standard record?
The same exercise.
Equals to 1.2 ... we have only one digit
between 1 and the decimal point.
This is 1.2 by 10 ^ 1, or 1.2 by 10,
which is definitely equal to 12.
Let's do a few examples in which we have 10 on
negative.
Let's say we have 0.00281 and we want to write this
with standard recording.
What you have to do is just think
how many digits are to include the leader
figure in value?
What I mean is to list 1,2,3.
The thing we want to do is move
the decimal point with 1, 2, 3 places.
One way of thinking is that you can multiply.
To move the decimal point to the right with 3 spaces,
you can multiply by 10 ^ 3.
But if you multiply something by 10 ^ 3,
you change its value.
You have to multiply by 10 to -3.
That way you will not change the value, do you?
If I multiply it by 10 ^ 3, 10 on a negative 2 ... 3 ...
minus 3 is 0 ... this is exactly like the multiplication of 1.
What will be equal?
If I take the decimal point and move it with 3 spaces to the right,
this part here will be 2.81.
Then we stay with that 1, 10 at
negative grade 3.
A very quick way to do is to say: Let's
count ... including the leading figure ... how many positions
I have the decimal point.
1, 2, 3.
Will be equal to 2.81 at 10 on
negative 1, 2, 3 degree.
Let's do another one like that.
Let me move up.
Let's say I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 ... how many zeros I have
in this task?
I'll think of something.
0, 2, 7.
We want to write this with a standard record.
Count all items to
2, after the decimal point.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
This will be 2.7 by 10 at
the negative 8 degree.
Let's make another where to start
with the standard record and we want to go
to the numerical value.
Just to mix things up.
Let's have 2,9 by 10 on
grade -5.
One way of thinking is: the leading figure, plus all
zeros to the left of the decimal point,
are 5 characters.
When you have 2 and 9 then you will
you got 4 more zeros.
1, 2, 3, 4.
And you get your decimal mark.
How do I know about 4 zeros?
Because the numbers are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 positions after
the decimal point, including the leading figure.
That's 0.00029.
To check, do it another way.
How do I write this with a standard record?
I count all the characters, all zeros after
the decimal character, including the leading non-zero digit.
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 characters.
This is 10 of the negative 5.
It will be 2.9 at 10 in grade -5.
Once again, this is not simple
a kind of black magic.
There is logic in that.
If I wanted to make that figure at 2.9, what I was going to do
to do is to shift the decimal point with 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 positions in this way.
And to move the decimal point to the right with 5 places ...
let's say 0, 0, 0, 0, 2, 9.
If I multiply it by 10 ^ 5, I will have to
multiply by 10 ^ (-5).
I do not want to change the number.
This is just a multiplication of something 1.
10 -5 in 10 (-5) is 1.
Indeed, this will move here
the decimal point 5 to the right.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
That will be 2.5 and we will stay after that
10 (-5).
Still, I hope you find this exercise
for the standard recording as useful.